comenzamos marcando la vuelta de
washington al combate contra el cambio
climático
la cumbre virtual de dos días que
comienza el jueves será el primer gran
evento sobre el medio ambiente de la
administración de joe biden asistirán 40
líderes mundiales pero la mayor atención
se centrará en el propio baile
esquerda el compromiso de eeuu tras unos
años fuera de la mesa del clima es algo
que la gente observará para asegurarse
que son serios y están comprometidos
pero no hay duda que necesitamos que un
país de la talla de eeuu sea parte de la
solución y no del problema si queremos
salir adelante como planes de solución
el bahiense ha comprometido a trabajar
para que eeuu sea neutro en carbono para
2050 el objetivo de la cumbre es en
efecto animar a los países a que asuman
compromisos más firmes en cuanto a las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
y justamente sentados a la mesa de
negociaciones estarán los mandatarios de
los países más emisores del mundo como
el líder chino xi jinping el primer
ministro indio
vendrán modi representantes de la unión
europea así como el presidente ruso
vladimir putin
el volumen acumulado de emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero en rusia
debería ser menor en los próximos 30
años que en los últimos 30 años debería
ser menor que en la unión europea otra
potencia responsable de buena parte de
las emisiones contaminantes china su
líder
jinping asistirá a la cumbre a través de
un vídeo y beijing ya se comprometió a
alcanzar la neutralidad de carbono para
2060 la semana pasada el enviado de eeuu
para el clima john kerry se encontraba
en china en un acercamiento que abre una
esperanza de que las dos partes puedan
unir esfuerzos en esa dirección también
están invitados países que ya están
sintiendo los efectos del cambio
climático y podrían sufrir sus peores
consecuencias como bangladesh jamaica
iqueña el mundo entero estará pendiente
de las decisiones que tomen las grandes
potencias para preservar el planeta